how are you making sure that your highly
sensitive information
is protected while you're running it hi
my name is alex ger from the ibm cloud
team and make sure to like and subscribe
so before i get started talking about
confidential computing i want to talk a
little bit about why it's such an
exciting field
so confidential computing among other
reasons is exciting for the fact that
we're seeing cross-collaboration
in the tech space to actually drive the
the technology forward and so it's
awesome to see people reaching across a
competitive
aisle to do that a lot of bright minds
the second is that the technology
is going to directly complement the
existing data encryption paradigm that
we have today
and make it an even more complete
end-to-end story
so before i get into the actual
technology and some of the use
and value behind it let's start with the
existing pillars of data encryption
today
so you start with protecting your data
while it's at rest so when you're
storing it
so we've got at rest you can think of
this as whatever information you'd like
to
we'll just represent it simply here now
we have information that we want to
transit from point to point so in order
to do that securely we need to protect
it
while it's in transit so we say n
transit
but what's missing in today's story is
this third pillar here
what are you doing to protect it while
you're actually running it
the groups you're going to have to
protect yourself against one are
malicious actors who want to do things
like
scrape that data you're also going to
want to protect against memory dumps
things of that nature
we have the inevitable threat that we
have to protect against which is insider
threats
and in addition we also have a lot of
collaboration that we want to go on
between us and either a trusted vendor
or even a trusted technology partner
but at the same time we really don't
want to expose a piece of highly
sensitive information to them
even though we want them to be able to
take advantage of it so we've got also
our partners and vendors here
how can we ensure that this information
is not only
um not visible to these parties but also
protected
from the worst case scenario that's
where confidential computing goes
in so let's talk about what confidential
computing looks like
we earlier talked about the
collaboration across technology leaders
in the space
we at ibm are a part of the confidential
computing consortium so the definition
that we follow for confidential
computing
is as such confidential computing is a
hardware-based technology that allows
for the physical partitioning
of memory at the server level so let's
draw our stack
we've got our hardware level on the
bottom which is where the actual
physical
partitioning of the memory is going to
take place
and then we have the middleware level
and then for the example but not
exclusive to we're going to talk about
any containerized abstraction of this
so we're going to have containers here
so what's taking place is that at the
hardware level we have that physical
partitioning of the memory
which allows for you to actually run
that application in its own silo
so the silo in the scenario that we've
painted here is going to be called an
enclave
so we've got an enclave here one two
three etcetera etcetera etcetera
etcetera so these enclaves
can have applications run in that that
physically isolated environment
but let's take a look into more detail
about what that actual enclave is
so the enclave itself functions like a
black box so to speak
this black box or enclave
has that data that we spoke about
earlier
we'll make it the same one from our
previous example but what it also has in
here are the set of techniques or
the things that or the actual processing
and the procedures for that processing
that information so we've got our
techniques here
what this system does in a scenario in
which we had the malicious actor from
earlier we had the insider threat
and we even had our own partners
what it does is it has an encryption key
that it only extends out
to the authorized program
that allows for that authorized program
to decrypt the information running
within this physically isolated silo
and to be able to actually perform its
set of processes
so this authorized program can do so but
that key is not extended to the other
parties so that
that right privilege since it's not
offered here prevents the access from
for a malicious actor it prevents the
access
to an insider threat and then finally it
even prevents access
to a partner what actual access is it
preventing now
this is access to modify that code as
well as and
to to view that data while it's actually
inside this physically
partitioned silo but what's really
important for our design is that we
verify
that the interaction with that code or
data
was what we hope for it to be so we need
to have what we refer to as
attestation reports so at a station
reports you can see here
attestation reports
and just for good measure we've got in
here
that encryption key that we talked about
so let's get back to the key value
proposition we just discussed
so what this secure enclave this black
box allowed us to do
it gave us a data and code integrity
that we didn't have before
one it reduced the visibility of that
data while it was being run
only to the the authorized program
itself
so we have restricted visibility
the second is that it took that data and
it actually prevented
these parties from making any sort of
undue modification
to the actual code itself um so no mod
or unauthorized mod and then what we
were able to do was
verify the actual interaction with that
code and that data
via attestation reports which is very
critical
for um for corroborating the story that
our system
is telling us so now let's look at the
use cases that have been enabled
so the first use case here we're going
to talk about is multi-party computing
multi-party computing coming down to
right here we're actually working with
the technology partner it allows for us
to take highly sensitive information and
exchange it with other parties without
actually exposing it
so therefore what we can do is we can
share data sets we can actually
collaborate and perform functions
commonly on top of highly sensitive
information so you can think about maybe
a collaboration between
two research institutions who otherwise
in the past had to go around
a very complicated path for actually
getting approval to exchange that
information
now they've got that quick and easy path
by simply not allowing that
information to be exposed to the other
party the next case that we're going to
talk about
is ip so ip you can think of that next
great discovery that your company is
making perhaps you've
discovered some sort of pharmaceutical
innovation and you have the actual
um uh the blend or the chemical
composition and the other things that
are unique about your solution
and you're wanting to actually share
that with another party but again
without exposing that information to
them
so this is another great scenario where
you're protected
now the final one it's um it's a real
situation that we all have to tackle
today
is that we give the keys to the kingdom
essentially to the people that we trust
and we hire
but an insider thread is always a
possibility so we have to protect
our workloads from that possibility so
we have insider threats here
and now we've protected ourselves from
even the case in which our own turn on
us
so now that we've got the use cases laid
out you can see the clear value that is
provided by confidential computing
confidential computing is focused on
protecting application data while you're
actually
running it and it allows for us to be
able to
collaborate more freely with other
parties as well as protect ourselves in
a new way from malicious actors
whether external or internal thank you
for listening
if you have questions please drop us a
line below if you want to see more
videos like this in the future
please like and subscribe and don't
forget you can grow your skills and earn
a badge with ibm cloud labs which are
free browser-based interactive
kubernetes labs